друзья Я хотел бы сегодня с вами
порассуждать на тему сколько денег нужно
человеку для жизни очень часто эту фразу
ещё произносят в таком иронично ключе
сколько денег нужно для счастья помните
в этом плане в фильме по-моему 12 ульев
Киса Воробьянинов там вплоть до копейки
привёл пример когда ему нужно там
сколько-то рублей сколько-то копеек К
сожалению в этом вопросе большая
Путаница многие люди не до конца
понимают что сколько на самом деле денег
нужно для того чтобы заработать Почему
важно досмотреть это видео потому что в
этом видео Мы попытаемся разобрать и мы
разберём Сколько максимум денег нужно
для жизни Сколько нужно для жизни
миллиардера миллионера И вообще сколько
нужно в вашем конкретном случае Итак
поехали и первое с чего я хотел бы
сегодня начать это поговорить о том о
той максимальной сумме денег которая
нужна челове для жизни всё что выше этой
планки человеку для жизни не нужно это
уже излишки Денег которые может быть
нужны для того чтобы реализовывать
какие-то грандиозные
планы там мечталки реализовываться
человеку самому и так далее но эти
деньги точно ему нужны Не нужны для
жизни и для примера Давайте разберём
жизнь миллиардера Мы же все представляем
что жизнь миллиардера - это какая-то
особая жизнь жизнь по максимуму так вот
я вам скажу что среди миллиардеров тоже
разные бывают люди например тот же урен
баффет всю жизнь прожил в одном доме 60
лет жил в одном доме которой он в своё
время купил там в 60х годах у себя в
штате Небраска его партнёр Чарльз
мунген доме Хотя это два супер
миллиардера и таких примеров на самом
деле очень много если мы представим
жизнь миллиардера который хохочет жить
на полную катушку не так как эти люди о
которых я вам только что привёл пример
то давайте представим сколько нужно
Максимум для жизни миллиардера мы позже
разберём И сколько нужно для жизни
миллионера И сколько нужно в вашем
конкретном случае поэтому а продолжайте
смотреть это раскроет вам горизонты и
понимание того сколько нужно Максимум в
среднем И сколько нужно для вас для того
чтобы жить максимальной жизнью
миллиардера Я считаю достаточно иметь
100 млн долларов всё что выше 100 млн
долларов на вашу жизнь уже никакого
эффекта оказывать не будет если у вас
есть 100 млн долларов которые приносят м
12% годовых Я считаю это вполне по силам
Если вы заработали 100 млн долларов
найти инвестиции куда вы можете
разместить чтобы зарабатывать 12 млн
долларов или 12% годовых а то это
получается 1 млн долларов в месяц Что на
это можно купить И что И что Какой
жизнью можно жить можно тратить А в год
по-2 млн долларов на аренду яхты аренда
яхта в среднем обходит от 500 до 700.000
долларов в неделю эта яхта там от 70 м и
больше то есть чем не жизнь миллиардера
2-3 недели проводить на яхте когда у
меня была у самого семидесяти тровато
Максимум что я в год проводил 4 недели я
проводил на своей яхте больше у меня
просто с одной стороны и не хотелось с
другой стороны и не получалось поэтому
аренда яхты полёт на своём частном
самолёте 25 млн долларов плюс полёты на
вертолётах плюс социальные какие-то
обязательства благотворительности и так
далее плюс бюджет своей семьи короче 12
млн долларов вы будете жить полной яркой
жизнью миллиардера и ни в чём себе
практически не отказывать Сколько нужно
для того чтобы жить жизнью миллионера
давайте тоже посмотрим вам нужно иметь
10 млн долларов если вы имеете 10 млн
долларов и Разместили их по 12% годовых
это вам будет давать 100.000 долларов в
месяц на ваши расходы на 100.000
долларов в месяц на ваши расходы Вы
вполне можете арендовать даже в
самом дорогом городе мира в нью-йорке Вы
можете арендовать приличную очень
хорошую квартиру Не говоря уже там о
таких городах как Москва Киев Алмата
Ташкент и так далее Вы можете иметь
очень крутую машину А и вы не будете
париться по поводу ваших путешествий
отдыхов э куда-то за границу а насчёт
питания обучения детей и так далее вы
будете жить нормальной хорошей жизнью
обычного миллионера Я только что
разобрал основные клише и будем так
говорить основные хотелки или мечталки
большинства людей о том как жить жизнью
миллиардера и жизнью миллионера а
сколько вам нужно денег для жизни где
эти нормативы Кто устанавливает эти
нормативы это что минимальная
потребительская корзина или там
правительства какие-то ещё нормативы
устанавливают и так далее и так далее
Это не те обще установленные нормы
которые установлены там по которым надо
жить та сумма денег которая необходима В
вашем случае она определяется по
определённому алгоритму Давайте я вам
расскажу об этом Для начала я уверен у
большинства
99% людей этого нет Если можно сказать
99 99% людей этого нет для этого сначала
для того чтобы определить сколько денег
вам нужно вы сначала Опишите картинку
своей идеальной жизни то есть картин
той жизни которой вы хотите жить как
можно подробнее В каком доме Вы хотели
бы жить в каком городе Вы хотели бы жить
в какой части города Вы хотели бы жить
Какая квадратура дома в каком стиле дом
Вы хотели бы какая территория Как вы
хотите на чём вы хотите ездить на каких
машинах как вы будете одеваться Где вы
хотели бы чтобы учились ваши дети как вы
хотели бы питаться куда еди Ездить
отдыхать и где отдыхать Почему важно
описать эту идеальную картинку вашей
будущей жизни потому что вы знаете я
много раз убеждался что люди когда
начинают жить жизнью миллионера или
миллиардера она не всегда их устраивает
поэтому Например у себя я это прописал
таким образом чтобы одна из моих целей
жить такой обеспеченной жизнью которая
максимально возможно в рамках моих
желаний не в рамках моих финансовых
возможностей А в рамках моих желаний
большинство людей хотят жить на полную
катушку на всю на это настолько
насколько им позволяют финансы а так как
у меня финансов достаточно Я
ограничителем ставлю настолько насколько
позволяют мои желания У меня например
финансовые возможности есть там жить
более роскошной жизнью А я не хочу
например поэтому очень важно
ограничителем ставить свои желания а не
финансовые возможности Итак таким
образом Сначала вы описываете идеальную
картинку жизни кото те жить просто
пофантазируйте Садитесь
Многие могут подумать что идеальная
картинка жизни это вот жизнь миллиардера
или миллионера сразу начнут яхты
самолёты Поверьте мне не каждый человек
хочет яхты самолёты и так далее может
быть один раз в жизни попробовать
достаточно но большинство людей на самом
деле мечтает о вполне нормальных хороших
условиях не так чтобы супер супер
финансово каких-то затратных поэтому не
бойте фантазию пофантазируйте но
единственный вопрос не преследуете тот
образ жизни который навязывается Вам
социальными сетями и общественными
нормами послушайте своё сердце и один на
один когда никто вам не мешает Напишите
реально какой идеальной жизнью вы хотели
бы жить в каком доме на чём ездить куда
Ездить отдыхать где чтобы учились ваши
дети и так далее и так Дале после того
как Вы всё это писали Назовите это
стандартом вашей идеальной жи зни Таким
образом у вас появился стандарт вашей
идеальной жизни то к чему надо
стремиться И после этого вы просто
берёте и начинаете каждый пункт этой
идеальной жизни оцифровывать такой дом в
таком городе в таком-то районе будет
стоить примерно такой-то берёте среднюю
цену ставить там условно 300.000
долларов или 200.000 долларов или там
500.000 долларов дальше машины на
которых я хочу ездить А для я сам и моя
супруга например они будут стоить
столько-то вот модели вот цены дети Я
хочу чтобы они учились в таких-то школах
Это стоимость обучения такая-то таким
образом вы вторым шагом первый шаг - это
описание своего
стандарта жизни а вторым шагом вы просто
бюджетирования Сколько денег Вам
необходимо для обеспечения вашей
идеальной жизни Таким образом у вас
появляются две цифры первое ТО Сколько
нужно вам на покупку
тех вещей которые обеспечивают ваш
идеальный стандарт жизни то есть на
покупку дома машин и так далее а вторая
цифра это сколько нужно вам денег для
поддержания этого уровня жизни почему
это разные две цифры должны быть первое
Когда вы покупаете дом это же
одноразовая
покупка вы покупаете машину это тоже
одноразовая покупка но в то же время у
вас есть расходы которые будут уходить
на содержание этого дома на содержание
этой машины плюс у вас расходы будут на
оплату обучения детей и так далее
поэтому обязательно нужно разделить на
капитальные расходы То есть те деньги
которые уйдут на покупку и на
операционные расходы которые пойдут на
покрытие расходов по поддержанию вашего
идеального образа жизни исходя из этих
двух видов расходов у вас появляются две
цели первая цель сколько вам нужно денег
накопить или заработать для того чтобы
купить тот дом ту машину и так далее
второе сколько вы должны иметь
регулярных доходов ежемесячных э которые
будут покрывать ваши ежемесячные расходы
на поддержание этого образа жизни Таким
образом у вас появилось две цели далее У
вас есть финансовые цели вы пишите
финансовую стратегию план в течение
времени которого вы этого планируете
достичь У вас есть конкретные цели
конкретные действия вы понимаете Для
чего вы зарабатываете проблема ещё
многих бизнесменов если не большинства
заключается в том что они просто
зарабатывают деньги а на самом деле
бизнес Это только инструмент для
зарабатывания денег необходимых для
обеспечения вам идеальной вашей жизни
Вот это важно не путать многие
бизнесмены занимаются зарабатываем денег
как самоцелью и у них даже когда бизнес
построили деньги появились они не знают
куда тратить
а почему не знает куда тратить потому
что у них нету стандарта идеальной жизни
Вы должны чётко понимать сначала
стандарт вашей идеальной жизни и под неё
вы начинаете заниматься бизнесом и
зарабатывать деньги после того как вы
обеспечили стандарт вашей идеальной
жизни все деньги сверху Вы можете
Пускать на реализацию своих амбиций уже
там менять мир там запускать корабли на
просторы просторы вселенной и так далее
но первая цель любого бизнеса - это
финансовое обеспечение вашего идеального
стандарта жизни К сожалению в
современное время в социальных сетях
везде рисуется картинка идеальной жизни
Lamborghini
rolls-royce там вертолёты и так далее
красивая картинка и этот образ жизни
навязывается вам на самом деле он не
является вашим идеальным образом жизни
поэтому вот Как отделить Что является
вашим идеальным образом жизни или и той
картинкой которой вам которую вам
навязали прежде всего смотрите Вы должны
сделать что уединиться поймать паузу
послушать своё сердце послушать свои
желания и написать то что вы считаете
будет идеальным для вас При этом если в
вашу идеальную картинку будущей жизни
залез залезли такие вещи как Lamborghini
и так далее и вы искренне считаете что
это ваше то на Первые накопленные деньги
не пате Lamborghini а просто Возьмите в
аренду на недельку это гораздо дешевле
поездить на нём поездить на нём там вы
можете поехать в Дубай и взять в аренду
любую машину неделю поедите и вы поймёте
Это Ваша машина или нет потому что
нельзя путать идеальную картинку которую
вы увидели в социальных сетях и
реальность так вот я ездил на всех этих
машинах и Lamborghini и Ferrari и на
всех я Вам скажу такое ощущение что ты
задницей по асфальту едешь и чувствуешь
Тош каждую кочку и каждый камушек на
асфальте ну супер некомфортные машины
Мне они лично абсолютно не нравятся
поэтому я так и не заболел этой болезнью
А я сам например езжу на Toyota Лан
крузере и мне выше крыши удовлетворяет
эта машина поэтому не спешите покупать а
сначала Возьмите в аренду и поживи этой
жизнью Поэтому если вашу картинку мира
закрались таки вещи которые вы не
уверены это ваше истинное желание или
навязанное лучше Возьмите в аренду
поживи этой жизнью проверьте и после
этого вы поймёте это ваше или нет помимо
тех лайфхаков э и тех мыслей которые вам
сегодня дал Я ещё по многим вещам
рассуждаю размышляю в своём Telegram
канале поэтому переходите по ссылке
Внизу там вы можете дальше получать
различные э там лайфхаки или мой стиль
стиль и образ жизни здесь ещё очень
важно отметить такую вещь
смотрите до тех пор пока вы не
Определите ту сумму которая вам
действительно нужна для вашей жизни у
вас не будет ориентиров финансовых
ориентиров сколько зарабатывать и что
для этого делать поэтому обязательно моя
рекомендация в этом видео самое главное
Создайте стандарт своей жизни стандарт
вашей жизни и будет той путеводной
звездой и финансовой целей целью к
которой вы должны стремиться всей своей
деятельностью особенно с деятельностью